For this problem, imagine that you're at a gym.
Here you are and you're going to get some exercise by lifting weights,
in particular, this 25 kg weight and you're going to lift it at a height of 1 m
and you're just going to keep repeating lifting and lowering the weight to get some exercise.
Assume for this problem that you only do work when you're lifting the weight.
When you lower it, you don't spend any energy and you don't get any energy back either.
Let's assume you do 2/3 repetitions per second where each repetition
is one raising and lowering of the weight, and let's assume you are doing a 4-minute workout.
Now I want you to tell me how many calories will you burn
if 1 calorie is equal to 4200 joules--good luck.